welcome to this video playing never mind
teammate of mine let's see what we got
wanted to do something else playing
playing G 30 s invited a bit tricky to
play against player where you very much
knowing what is going to do I mean
knowing what is going to do is normally
helpful but if you play lots of the same
opening so that you play yourself ok we
get something very often referred to as
the brick clamp where why this setting
up a big center with D for later let's
see if I get get this in default maybe
Queenie to deform ok no black is playing
with e 5 maybe I should have played d
for earlier now deform I guess he will
take on F form
is f five possible here or here well
he's ready for d5 I cannot really not
sure about it take special bait 3d
five-night h1 tags okay come on some
okay I really thought I thought more
about the capture but ok that the file
is obviously not a bad move playing in
the center is rarely wrong I mean you
can argue about alternatives but it is
really not as never bad okay it takes
see takes I'm going to go to see for
interesting yeah this is an interesting
choice yeah still to see for I guess
yeah if he takes that's interesting
Bishop age 3 is normal setting up the
pin
yeah but black wants to do is break
through in the center be 5c four would
be excellent to achieve i really need
i'm not sure if he what they should do
now maybe taking what don't get me wrong
if i say i'm not sure what you should do
at the minis in trouble black ass up
very likely and very in good shape but
it's um it's some difficult to play okay
so probably to d2 right now let's or
yeah let's go back first i also might
have night d3 at ya now I wanted a will
take here with 94 being a possibility or
is there something else this should be
okay the night to e4 should be worth
something
very very complicated position yeah
that's in fact from a common
misconception and people think that Oh
moves like g3 are not i'm not very very
fighting in a way that sets not true you
quite often get the positions where this
whole pieces are on the board and it's
very hard to figure out what what's
happening this is also very complicated
stuff maybe I should have gone to g2 way
I was unsure he's got this 93 business
but now can I need to go to you for any
way it son if he goes to e3 app I'm not
sure what to do I should have gone to
that too what is this piece doing on g4
anyway I was thinking that maybe after I
have six or something I can put it on 85
but Oh Jim
I don't really know if I can make some
sort of peace some sort of exchange the
second out of this probably not check
the bishop on g2 would be much better
yeah because of this stuff if always
hanging if it was on g2 this is this
wouldn't work at all okay um anyway f6
it's not really on Play wiki modern goes
back a bishop mother says maybe I can
take d 3 what the heck can just take d3
jataka and simply bear we can just take
Quinn text III have I just overlook the
smooth very stupid very stupid stuff and
totally unnecessary totally
95 Bishop takes it for that I don't have
something else yeah Bishop g4 was was
the first step in the in the wrong
direction why isn't he just taking a fun
okay okay this isn't this isn't
fantastic but I thought them here I
might have slight chances to fight due
to the opposite colored bishops but it's
not really anything serious not really
time warning
yeah okay that's good Bishop c3m strong
yeah totally unnecessary loss of course
white resigns yeah Bishop to g4 is the
first run or we had move yeah bishop I
don't know I don't know well I'm not
sure about the position but I don't
think I need to lose as check simply as
I did how black is better anywhere but
this is just just totally jataka like I
can like you should just take here and
and and see what words lead to what it's
leading to Bishop takes I guess Shack
after this Bishop f3 is quite okay this
ideas this is ok I also threatened c5 so
takes TX Bishop f3 takes Jenn tags and
don't have I initially thought that this
might be okay but he has see phone it's
got c4 yeah well that's not good no
that's not good okay this means that the
whole thing is is bad really should h3b
5626 CF queen age 6
here to computer points out 94 maybe
yeah the whole concept is of course is
of course risky because I give him some
edge in the center with c 5 t for
computer wants to go here yeah but it's
a bit like fishing and then muddy waters
probably this wasn't a good idea this is
a 5 business should maybe just play a
normal move here or instead of going
here start with D for this is what white
wants to do in the long run anyway maybe
this wasn't a good game okay thanks for
watching